welcome to the team mr. wise thank you
now being an Arizona assistant state's
attorney it's an important job one we
take very seriously in fact we are
willing to do anything to win it's my
honor sir and I look forward to serving
the state of Arizona are these marbles
how's that
it's just admiring your container of
marbles by years my wife got them for me
as a gift from a birthday which brings
me to a speech I like to give anyone on
their first day here at the state's
attorney office of Arizona you see Lady
Justice is a committed woman she's a
slippery little scallop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on what what are you doing
oh I marbles they're just I gotta tell
you they're just so beautiful but I was
wondering what it would feel like did in
my mouth like what would the few marbles
feel like if they were in my mouth
you know what just you know you know
like this what would it feel like if
they were just kind of a whole ton of
marbles in my in my face
well don't do that just just don't do
that yeah yeah of course of course
why what am i doing over here I mean
that's that's a thing that a child would
do it is you were saying I was saying
that Lady Justice just stands there in
my office looking at
[Music]
forget the marbles boy spit the marbles
out please
there you go well how many really do you
have any I'm gonna wait for the last I'm
assuming this yeah I know there's
another one in there nope all right I am
just I'm they're just so beautiful I
can't it's these marbles I got to tell
you you obviously don't take this job
seriously sir it's just these particular
marbles I just needed to feel what they
felt like in my mouth I don't know what
is wrong with me
you know we do serious business here
right yes I do know that I'm a hundred
percent aware of that yeah because I've
forgotten where our walls were saying
that justice is a dumb blind old lady I
heard yes no she's not dumb was he is
blind
she's reminiscent of a Kara Washington
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Jannis sending the cleanup crew another
one fell for the marble trick
[Music]
you
you